what was it like hanging out with  rihanna and have you guys kept in touch  um no unfortunately we have not kept in  touch  how was it like sweetie it was  definitely life-changing a moment of my  life that i will never forget if y'all  ever see those articles about written  about rihanna and how she smells good  just know that they have not lied a day  in their life and rihanna actually  smells like heaven  do you have a favorite tick tocker i  have a bunch actually i mean the gen z  generation is just so crazy and chaotic  and so maybe maybe i could recommend  something rico taquito is really funny  oh this rg guy he is so funny and he's  always dancing with his chickens  and i love claire drake and wisdom care  who's the last celeb you texted and can  you read the text  oh my gosh okay yeah i don't know  i don't be talking to celebrities i  guess i don't have any celebrity texts  i'll just drink to that because i don't  have any